[Music]  you clean that lab you get out  she depth me she can hear you  the thing we keep in there is in the  front and I should know I dragged it all  the way here it's a lot of blood what  went on again it was you that found my  fingers there was mustard on me Soviets  want it we know that much we need to  take it apart learn how it was what  happened it's an animal just keeping it  table who needs to Jewish I can either  save him I let him down  don't do this alasa don't do this I'm  gonna be synchronizing our watches just  like they do in the movies Oh woman we  gonna burn in hell  [Music]  the asset do you have it  sure I'm getting it back our concern is  the Russians and [ __ ] this mess you  delivered right right  we didn't see nothing what am i doing  interviewing the [ __ ] cleaners he's a  wild creature we can't ask him to be  anything else  you were speaking Russian Bob  [Music]  finish the job  iliza honey he's coming for you  [Music]  you  you